hi i'm jesse cox and these are my
parents i'm susan cox and i'm jack cox
what do you know about final fantasy
it sounds like it's the last one of
whatever it is you're actually kind of
right final fantasy the very first one
was the developer's last attempt at a
game before they were like we're going
to quit so it was their final attempt to
get any other
yeah it was very successful so it's not
their final fantasy though no how ironic
based on this name final fantasy and
walker what do you think it's about and
water
walker
well that sounds like the end of the
game for sure and walker i would think
it'd just
be like
what do you call it zombies
zombies
well dad's right it is the end of this
story
you get to watch the trailer
for
the game
oh
he's cute
[Music]
obviously there's a fight and we're
fighting some monster just had his tail
cut off which is i think it's kind of
great
[Music]
what
why that man has a tie on
he has a tie on him yeah the tire wait
wait wait i got to see that beautiful
with the tie on
[Music]
oh so this is a world for the war for
the world
that's why it's called end walker it is
ah
in en walker yeah there are new primals
and this is one
what do you think of this
oh i said here's my
money here's the keys to my car
let me show you where it's parked yeah
another thing that you can do now you
can also run dungeons and raids i know
what a raid is what is a race a raid is
when you go and try and kill a bunch of
other people
it's not bad all right so i'm going to
show you
a part of a dungeon from end walker this
is the tower of zot
it's colorful it's looks like there's a
lot of activity taking place somebody's
killing somebody else it looks like in
here this is the boss in the middle
they've got to get him these are people
actually playing right now yes
but what is a boss
wow
so we
got to experience a little bit of final
fantasy 14 and walker let's create a
character for you
where's the ones that had the
bunny ears down here
yeah yeah yeah
yeah let's do money okay i want it to be
kind of gross
big and gross it's not just little time
all right sweet i don't want to be great
i can tell you've been married a long
time
all right so you have different faces to
choose from here
oh yeah yeah yeah i like the mean thing
i'm going to fight a war
i don't want to look like i want you to
come to me i want to fight you so i
would probably pick that thing right you
were talking about earlier about the
bunny boys having too much clothes on
oh my god that's like a little too much
club a little too much clothes don't put
you
i think that's what you really meant
no no no no no put it on is there a
medium close we named this character
that's the most important part my man
what would you like to name this
character fandor
t-h-a-n-d-o-r vandoor vandoor he's the
name you came up with that's pretty bad
so we're gonna look through a bunch of
jobs and you're going to tell me what
you think they are and at the end which
one you want to be
all right what do you think about this
character
i would say
that this character
is an enticer
because of the type of weapon that's
where you got the enticement from yes
what you didn't get that no no
you didn't see that but here's the thing
you somehow got there because that's a
dancer
and uh it's a ranged physical dps what
do you think dps stands for dangerous
person of substance dangerous person of
substance is the official answer now
all right next
uh oh this is one of the two new jobs in
en walker
it's a brand new character to gain i
think she's a a he or he's a beautician
a beautician could that knows all the
barbers tools the razors and stuff
there's just no thinking about
merlin that kind of thing do you know
what i'm trying to say i'm blown away
right now because this
is a sage
very merlin-esque i would say did i say
doctor you said i believe you said
barber
next uh this is another new job
yeah what does this look like to you
it's like a seat
a seat a sith a scythe
it depends what part of pittsburgh
you're from
well i'm more concerned about the thing
behind that character the repo
did you come back kid from downtown the
reaper
so you learned about the game we've
created a character you've experienced
the world itself so now i would like you
to tell me what you learned about final
fantasy 14 and walker i have never seen
a game where you have so many different
details that you can apply to the game
and create a character and i think a lot
of folks are going to enjoy
the fact that they have that kind of
detail that you're able to choose from
what about you
well if i have more time i'd spend more
time on developing my character the
character really got you i like the
character yes the vera the male veer is
very popular right now yeah i really
everyone's trying to i really like it
yeah final fantasy 14 and walker is
available now to download and play
[Music]